signori siamo di fronte a quelli
intramontabile capolavoro chiamato
scrive il punto io che era da un po che
non facevo quel gioco di disegnare un po
di roba e far vedere che sei un po un
pon picasso dalì mancato soprattutto
mancato la parola giusta
[Musica]
me la ricordavo giorni un gioco di
hovercraft ok ci siamo o siamo su una
lobby italiana bellissimo non si chiama
fra vj ok perché c'è gente che gioca
scrivo contenuto il mio nickname non ci
giocavo da una vita
chissà quanta gente o ho coniato bello
però questa posso già indovinare anch'io
che mi sono inserito a ghigliottina
esatto esatto bravo normale anomala dato
me l'ha dato
me l'ha dato lo stesso allora favo
eccomi la disegno io la disegno io ce
l'ho ragazzi questo è facile questo è
facile allora un favo molto easy ok
aspetta aspetta aspettate che questa è
quella giusta
ok con le cuffie con le mani sulla
scrivania ma che dopo col joystick a
tastiera che è meglio dai sono io si
vede sono io ma che film porno dai un
favo cos'è un favo meno i gay perché i
geni non c'è però il pezzo prima il
pezzo prima c'era ma porca vacca non
siete furbi solo foste furbi vabbè dai
poi fra vj fammi vedere quanto ti meriti
questo nickname
tanto ci sembrano dire sembrava morpheus
di matrix camion di smetto
se quello vero si no è un fake ma come
ti permetti madonna fai schifo fra vj
non è un eterno sono nate però porca
vacca cos'è ci sono due coccodrilli ma
quando iscritto
ma cos'è normale ma qualcosa in un
geroglifico più e più interpretabile
spiega in questo schifo fa il felino is
nothing to keep fra vj botkin fra
vigenti
ho votato per cliccare il mio soldi al
torino che è disegno de mer di isola di
pasqua aveva anche scritto pasqua si
isola madonna ma un bambino di 0,1 anni
c'è ma spiegami ma cos'era
sternocleidomastoideo tensione la sua
idea perché io furbo sono io il vero
fare ma come ti per trattamenti per me
poi quella gente come mao ma questo
furto ma questo è furto di identità
entità la smette se non ho capito allora
pagina bandi e bandierona bandiera o
grossa no bandierona più piccola più
piccola
cos'è un forno a microonde madonna
quanto disegnate da cani ragazzi questo
capisci una piscina bar pallacanestro ci
sta a pallacanestro
io ti giuro che se prendo mia nonna mia
nonna cotto ma l'hai mai vista una
calcolatrice sai che ci sono i numeri 1
2 3 cos'è ma ci hai comitato sulla
calcola maki maki kato ma vostra madre
in autostrada ma non ho capito ma mi
chicano perché pensano che sia fake
terni ai ragazzi ho adesso mi chiamo
step di così almeno è un senso mammut
mammut mahmood armadio armadio armadio
né al mar armadio né grosso armadio
porta a porta a porta
il gigante cos'è madonna fate schifo
l'inter di armadillo per la disegnate un
armadio quando già la parola armadillo
cento va il crono siamo in tanti ad
indovinare questa parola vai diventa una
cosa io ho visto la pistola crono siamo
ultimi incredibile un team incredibile
alla chiusura del suoneria bossolo
blocco notes suoneria frana rara mi
chiamo virgola sono un gattino poca
gente si ricorda trovano in purtroppo no
anzi forse per fortuna è che un telefono
l'abbiamo capito zio però aspetta di
quello che c'è dentro vincono le colture
ok 1239 colore capito un telefono 5 6 7
8 9 0
mi chiamo virgola 48 tue 48 bravo bravo
stanno scrivendo il numero chiama manda
ciao e la ricevi subito in regalo
quanto basta basta con ste robe che poi
andiamo all'inferno tutti quanti io te
lo dico giampiero smettila di mettere
queste cose di video smettila scatola di
fazzoletti aggiornato la partita e poi è
uscito ottima allora mike social uomo
magro bimbo uomo persona persona 5 mar
morto morto era morto chiama my friends
subentra tanta gente che peccato perché
prima mi trovo bene con il mio crono
allora temperino a windows ma a cacare
quell'ora simbolo di windows e windows
via erca è figura che hai giocato la
partita picasso
ok nessuno saprà mai battermi con
neanche chi cazzo alla febbre bacchette
polpastrello allora io direi
polpastrello io riesco a fare il
polpastrello non è difficile ragazza era
vi invito a giornata la partita bella
bionda fosse un dito e poi c'è questo
[Musica]
dai poche calma oro ma questo madonna
svegliatevi cos'è un polpastrello poi il
passare sui disegni un caco così faccio
la porta e poi un pipistrello metti
insieme polpastrello porco demonio a
gesù dai crono dami soddisfazione bene
ciao mare è il fiume no linea linee
lines seta ultra torre di babele a un
palo era un palo era un palo per un palo
maledizione c'è ovunque ha vinto se ho
vinto io
bravo grazie arbitro calciatore si
giocatore are capitano ma no celo celo
celo bella zio miglia quanto sono stato
grande e bella bella solare più grande
però avevo già intuito da dal giallo o
intuito arbitro è incredibile e l'ha
disegnato anche bene tra l'altro non
avrei saputo disegnare così bello
eros o devi usare il cervello cicogna
bella mi sei piaciuto cicogna using a
world anatra no
bene ciao paolo mare lago a pino nobile
calze dominato prima bravo bravo e vino
tra l'altro vino mar.ma quanto rosa e
sangue colore vino va bene bravo bravo
mi è piaciuta
no c'è ma non c'e non e il carico e suri
knox la notte non è il creatore di
minecraft va bene allora aspetta con la
barbetta dai che ce la fate
dai che ce la fate porca vacca gli sta
veramente impegnato e brava cicogna
indovinato bravissima 500.000 cicogna la
indovinato incredibile bravo come che si
dice nozze si dice così ma non sono
anche come si pronuncia in realtà prove
[Musica]
denaro quella era una banconota quella
era una banconota amico mio ma tu sei ma
tu sei ma mai mi hai mai visto un soldo
e mi da due maledizione ma non c'entrava
niente
a pensavo fosse un pene gigante quello
ladro rapinatore pistolero a militare
con scritto prima di tutti perché sono
avanti quando uno scrive le cose bravo
quell'umidità quello era un casco mi
sembra un aureola zio prova fa niente
andrea a figo figurina e andrea pirlo
con la elle la o fuori dalla figurina
andrea pirlo madonna come come si vede
che pirlo è invecchiato mammamia pirlo
non è più quello di una volta
concludiamo per che guevara il mio
cervello sta esplodendo in questo però
ringrazio tutte le persone che ho
partecipato a questo video che
inavvertitamente mandato del fei
maledetti voi però che vi sia piaciuto
patrizia preso volete un atto scritto
appunto io che da un po che non lo
portavo secondo me merita sempre questo
gioco giuliano così episodio iscrivetevi
al canale schiacciata campanellina prima
regione di suoi video come se non ci
vediamo anno possiamo vino belle ragazze
[Musica]